We're going to do
a couple of results
with this formula that connect
even a little more with what
we're doing.
Maybe I'll leave
that blackboard here,
because [INAUDIBLE] simple
formulas come out of this,
which is very nice, actually.
So one simple formula was
that the total cross section--
we wrote the formula for the
differential cross-section.
But the total cross-section is
the integral of fk of theta,
in this case the omega.
So this is the integral
of fk of theta star
fk of theta with omega.
But we have fk of theta here.
That 0 looks like
theta, isn't it?
That's not good.
That's a 0.
And we can plug all this in.
So what do we have?
We do this because the
answer is very simple.
We get a 4 pi over k squared.
We have a sum over l and l prime
because we have two factors--
2l plus 1, 2l prime plus 1.
The phase shift for l prime
and the phase shift for l--
so e to the minus i
delta l sine of delta l.
So I guess I'm using l for this
one and l prime for that one.
e to the i delta l prime
sine of delta l prime.
But happily, all that will
not matter, because then you
have the integral over solid
angle of yl star 0 of omega
yl 0 of omega prime here.
Seems like a lot
of work, but we're
doing nothing else than
integrating this f of theta.
Let's look at it for a second.
It's just that formula squared.
So basically, you
star the one y.
You don't start the other, but
you have to integrate them.
And there orthonormality
of our spherical harmonics
means that this
is delta ll prime.
So you can set l
prime equal to l.
These phases will cancel.
This factor will be squared.
This square root will disappear.
And you have a simple formula
that the cross-section
is 4 pi over k squared sum 2l
plus 1 sine squared delta l.
Very nice formula for
a physical observable.
What did you get?
That the cross-section is
the sum of contributions.
The total cross-section
is the sum
of contributions from
partial cross-sections
from each partial wave.
That's not true for the
differential cross-section.
Because in the
differential cross-section,
you don't integrate.
And as long as you
don't integrate,
you have mixing
between different l's.
The different partial waves
interfere in the differential
cross-section, but they
will not interfere anymore
in the total cross-section.
Each partial wave contributes
to the total cross-section.
That's why it's important to
calculate this phase shift.
So you say, oh, just a phase.
Phases don't matter.
No.
The relative phases
matter a lot.
Those are the phases
that enter here,
and the cross-section
is expressed
in terms of those phases.
There's one more result
that is famous in scattering
and has to do with
the optical theorem.
The optical theorem
is something you
may have seen already
in electromagnetism
or in other fields.
It's a statement
about probability
of conservation of flux.
And it's fairly non-trivial,
and it's a constraint
on the scattering amplitude.
Basically-- and we may
discuss it in a problem.
It's the statement that
when you have an object,
the thing that you detect as
the scattering cross-section
is all these particles that
were deflected from the object.
And they were deflected
from the object
because the object
creates a shadow.
At least in the
electromagnetism,
that intuition is very clear.
You have a sphere here,
maybe a conducting sphere,
an observancy.
You shine light.
You create the shadow.
And that is the light that
if you didn't have here,
it would have gone through.
But if it's here, the
shadow is responsible.
What you lost from the shadow
is what you got scattered.
So whatever you get--
in the forward direction
here, you get nothing--
you get a shadow--
carries the information about
the wave that scattered.
It's a little more complicated
than that mathematically
when you do it, because
the total wave function
in the forward direction
is a combination
of the incoming
wave function that
has some forward direction and
the scattered wave function
that has a forward direction.
So the theorem is quite
interesting to prove,
and we prove it with
flux conservation
that gives you enormous
insight into the physics.
But here is the power of algebra
and the power of phase shifts.
You don't have to be brilliant
to discover the optical theorem
in this setup.
The physics has already done--
the mathematics
of the phase shift
has already done all
the work for you.
Let's see it happen.
Let's figure out how
does the forward--
the scattering cross-section
look in the forward direction.
So you have your object here.
You send in your waves.
They get scattered.
But there is something
in the forward direction.
That is fk at theta equals
0 is the forward scattering,
the word "scattering."
And now this forward
scattering is--
we can calculate it.
For that, we need to know
that yl 0 of theta equals 0--
well, yl 0 of theta
is actually 2l
plus 1 over 4 pi pl,
the Legendre polynomial
of cosine theta.
So yl 0 at theta equals 0
is just square root of 2l
plus 1 over 4 pi.
And the Legendre polynomials are
defined always so that pl at 1
is equal to 1.
All pl's at x equals
1 are always 1.
So that's the spherical harmonic
in the forward direction.
So you have here from that
formula on the right 4 pi
over k sum from l equals 0.
This is an investigation
of what happens
to the forward
scattering amplitude.
The yl 0 gives you another
square root of 2l plus 1
and a square root
of 4 pi as well.
And then you get e to
the i delta l sine delta.
So look here, here, and
these factors simplify.
So fk of theta equals 0 is 1
over k sum of l 2l plus 1 e
to the i delta sine delta.
That's a nice formula.
Maybe something-- it has
to do with a cross-section.
f in this forward
direction has that formula,
and the cross-section
has this formula.
So how do I get to relate them?
I get to relate
them if I set now--
I ask for the imaginary
part of this fk.
Because the imaginary part
of this fk at theta equals 0
is equal to 1 over k sum
over l, this 2l plus 1.
And the imaginary part of
that turns it into sine
squared delta, because the
imaginary part of the e to i
delta is sine delta.
So I get the sine
squared delta there.
And you say, look at this sum.
It's identical to the
sum of the cross-section.
You have discovered a relation
between the total cross-section
and the imaginary part of the
forward scattering amplitude.
So what is the final formula?
The final formula
is that sigma--
maybe I can do it here.
Sigma is equal to--
well, it differs at
least from a 4 pi
over k imaginary part of f of
theta equals 0, fk of theta.
This is the optical
theorem, which
was discovered in
the context of optics
by thinking of the
physics of shadows.
Whatever-- basically, the
shadow contains all that kind
of information
about all that was
lost from the incoming beam.
So that's a nice--
it's not absolutely
obvious how it
works, the process
of interference
between the incoming wave
and the scattered wave
and what they do.
And you have to look
carefully at this thing.
So that explains why you
need the imaginary part
and why these factors show up.
But the intuition is
nevertheless simple.